the french archives house a collection
of historical documents so vast they
could stretch all the way from paris to
england
hidden among those papers lie 15 letters
exchanged between french queen marie
antoinette and swedish count ochsel von
person antoinette's friend and rumored
lover who sought to rescue the queen and
her family during the french revolution
the highly secretive correspondence is
riddled with redactions commonly
attributed to the count's great nephew
100 years after their writing eager to
better understand the letters the
archives hired scientists to analyze the
ink in the redactions in writing to
unveil the hidden words their research
hinted at a surprising author of the
redactions
the count himself
other studies of handwritten documents
typically focus on text that is hidden
by happenstance such as letters rolled
up in delicate parchment that's easy to
damage
but this research was a little different
it investigated the willful redaction of
text with incan writing precisely
superimposed to hide the words beneath
after testing several techniques the
researchers found the best method to
uncover the words
using x-ray fluorescence to identify the
ink's chemistry different inks have
different impurities for instance some
contain more copper than zinc whereas
others will skew toward iron these
variations help the researchers classify
the inks used in the letters toward the
end of 1791 a variety of inks was used
to write the letters and make the
redactions
that meant the researchers could create
a virtual stack of the ink layers based
on their unique properties then they
could isolate the layers that contain
the original unredacted text after a
year of setting their parameters and
analyzing the data the researchers
surfaced the original words underlying
45 redacted lines
made my heart happy my dear
ez privudir
and i can tell you
nearly all had intimate connotations or
discuss plans to meet
you that i love and will love until
meanwhile information about political
events surrounding the royal family
wasn't redacted
i'm sending you a dispatch from berlin
but most impressive according to one
researcher was the revelation of who
likely authored the redactions she found
a single phrase that had been penned
from the same ink as the redaction
itself
the underlying papers were copies of
antoinette's letters in person's
handwriting
knowing the same ink was used for other
redactions across other sections of text
the researchers suspect the copies and
redactions must have been inked by
fersen
in the future this technique might help
piece together the history of other
mysterious documents
such as redacted early story drafts by
the french playwright balzac and misses
from napoleon
the uncovered words don't quite pin down
whether antoinette and person were
lovers or friends
but now we know there was more than what
meets the eye
[Music]
[Music]